what's happening then John right now
what's going on with all this epidemic
we've got the black lives matter
movement we've got the protests we've
got the corona we don't know whether
we're allowed in but we're allowed out
what's what's gonna happen what's your
perspective on this because I think a
lot of people are freaking out right now
well I mean every every so often every
so many centuries or decades or what we
have sometimes years we have you know
epidemics or in this case a pandemic and
that happens and there's a there'll be
some loss of life and there'll be some
empowered mewn systems and we'll learn
new things about biology and new things
about the immune system and new things
about society and we grow and life has
challenges and every time we face a
challenge as Bucky fuller says pollution
is future solution every time we have a
challenge we come up with new innovative
creative ideas and we come and
concretely going to the next challenge
so this is a temporary challenge it's
not gonna stop human beings it's going
to be a temporary little glitch for some
people only because they haven't seen
the time and adapted I always say the
inability to adapt to a changing
environment is what's called distress
and distress comes from the perception
of loss of that which you seek - the
perception of gain of that what you're
trying to avoid it if you're trying to
avoid something and seek the fantasy a
lot of people are depressed because
they're comparing their current reality
not to reality but comparing it to a
fantasy how it used to be in a fantasy
about how it's going to but it should
have been and they're not present with
what it is and then when they're present
with what is this how is this helping me
get what I want
and the depressions gone the pressures
of feedback to let you know that you're
expecting fantasies and unrealistic
expectations so whatever is happening
right now as far as I'm concerned it's
it's going to strengthen human beings
and make them more innovative and
creative and the online world has just
been boosted we've all become more
efficient
I mean Amazon has boomed the old
dinosaur type of businesses are going
out that's not anything but normal
evolution and that's before people that
had foresight are gonna boom the people
that had hindsight are gonna
that's the way it is that's the way the
evolution of consciousness works and so
I don't see anything out there except a
normal evolution we just have a new
challenge it's something we get to take
in but we will actually learn more about
the immune system more about physiology
health psychology a business it's only
going to make us more efficient and
effective in the future during the last
few months how are we going to go not me
but how is just general people
especially people that have necessarily
but gardens and haven't got necessarily
got families that are on their own how
people going to cope
are we going to fall into an actual
depression of the mind how do you think
what effect do you think hasn't a lot of
business owners of the Welcome Back
event you know rehung get on their
businesses of profited like you have
over the last few months what kind of
effect do you think is have on humanity
well depends on the individual you know
it's never what happens on the outside
it's what you decide to do with your
controlling only three things in your
life perception decisions and actions
you don't have control in the world
around you as much as you have the
control of your perception decisions and
actions around it so if you take the so
called thing around you and ask how
specifically can I use this to my
greatest advantage how's that helping me
fulfill my mission and answer that
question and see the upsides to what you
think is a downside it's not a downside
it's neutral so I don't if somebody
comes to me and running wanting to run
their story as a victim of history I
stop them in the middle story and said
I'm not the guy if you want to run a
story you go to a therapist for that if
you want to transform your life then
stop the story and let's find out how
this thing is actually helping you get
what you want and find out how it's on
the way not in the way and the moment
they do they change the story because
the stories most stories of emotions are
usually incomplete by asking question
houses helping you get what you want and
make them stop and go I never thought
about that well how is it helping you
never thought about it well think about
it
how's it helping you how can you use it
your greatest advantage what's the
opportunity sitting in front of you and
when they do that they find it and then
they turn it into opportunity so it's
just a matter of the attitude we
James said the greatest discovery of his
generation see human beings can alter
their lives not by altering their
perceptions and attitudes of mind so
true if we take the time to change our
perceptions and then if we make a
decision to change our actions and go to
high priority actions and ask what is
the highest priority action I can do
today to help me fulfill my mission on
earth and serve the greatest number of
people with the most sustainable fair
exchange way to earn the greatest income
so I can then delegate so I can stay on
the high priorities again if I do that
and ask that question and see things on
the way and ask priorities
there's no way what's happening on the
outside is gonna stop you from doing
what is inspiring to you on the inside